for me it was it was both the Epic and
the minutiae and specificity of the
small did you know there's a whole lot
more to Lord of the Rings the rings of
power than meets the eye we've gathered
a bunch of secret details you may have
missed like what the sets actually
looked like and what makes Prince
duren's beard so cumbersome
number one no stone was left unturned
everything including galadriel's dagger
was taken into account for the rings of
power series every character set and
wardrobe design was made so specifically
to immerse the actors and audience into
the imagined Middle Earth Daniel Wayman
was costume designer struck when he
realized he was getting lost in one of
his co-stars outfits hold on this
there's nothing that I never spotted
before and then but within that thing
there's another thing everything has
meaning we're gonna get into the sets
next since everything is so infinitely
detailed but now we can start to realize
why this production clocked in at nearly
500 million dollars to make number two
everyone was anticipating the new
original look of numenor and we were
stunned to get a short glimpse of it in
the trailer like everything behind the
scenes of this series it was built as
real as possible it was unprecedented
and one of the most extraordinary sets
utilizing the natural geography of New
Zealand it took set designers are
approximately five months to build talk
about some big dollars for one set you
won't be able to tell the difference
between a fake tree and a real tree on a
more comical note we bet you were
wondering where some of those bird feces
on the rooftops came from it was
actually a couple very lucky set workers
that got to layer on fake feces on the
roofs not a detail we would have ever
thought about but apparently they have
an explanation for everything number
three did you ever wish you had a beard
of many animals probably not and we're
sure Owen Arthur wishes he never had
after filming his scenes as Prince
during the fourth all that material in
one beard proved to be extremely
cumbersome on the actor's face Owen
explains the wig waste as much as a
newborn baby that's a lot to carry on
your chin and even show emotions with in
whole the piece consisted of human goat
horse and Yak hair but the real kicker
comes from how it was designed every
detail was considered the head of the
makeup and hair Department Jane okay
said we integrated real copper threads
to give it something unique in light
reflection and texture they were also
felt thread structures in the beard all
handmade it was an extensive jigsaw
puzzle of facial hair number four when
we say things needed to be specific we
weren't just saying all the things that
would be noticeable to the audience
production's attention to detail went
all the way down to the very leaves
placed on set maybe meticulously moving
a leaf and making sure it sat in the
right place we never thought leaves
would be so interesting but knowing that
even a simple leaf placement made a huge
difference on the production makes us
re-watch it even more number five who
doesn't like little hints of a
character's Destiny the writers of the
show are not just giving away important
plot points at the beginning they are
expertly dropping little hints as to
what will happen to each group of
characters yeah can't talk too much of
course the cast of this massive show
cannot leak any hints nor point the
audience at specific moments what they
are saying it will be pretty obvious
once the plot thickens you're on to
something in terms of like the energy
and the momentum that you've seen after
listening to what the cast said it looks
like we need to keep a close eye on
Bronwyn orindeer and Theo number six
working on location in New Zealand is a
privilege for the actors and crew making
performances and moods better New
Zealand where you just can anywhere you
go you couldn't be inspired by landscape
this country's fantasy and
malleable-like Landscape made it the
perfect location to build metal Earth
into for the actors and crew it was
extremely hard for them to remember they
were on the actual set it wasn't like
you saw the behind of the thing there
were layers upon layers upon layers of
things that were carefully crafted and
for a show of this caliber you'd think
CGI would be a major factor however for
show creators practicality was key for
their sets most of our sets were built
so we were actually there number seven
Peter Jack Jackson cemented the idea
that everything in a film needs to be as
real as possible for the showrunners of
the Rings of power they decided to give
a big budget to the Prosthetics and
makeup Department which makes sense
given that only 25 percent of the actors
casted played human characters and then
also great when you're on break and
you're like seeing an awk drinking a
smoothie or trying to eat a sandwich
this must have been incredibly fun for
the orc actors but a lot more tedious
work on the makeup artists to make each
one more unique from the last
number eight you may have thought the
elves were always graceful behind the
scenes however those small details in
morphid Clark's glad real costume cost a
lot of trips and choking people
constantly stepping on my train on my
cloak so I was getting slightly
strangled but it seemed like for many of
the actors who were donned in some sort
of armor or prosthetic were left
catching themselves falling to the
ground just listen to what these poor
Hobbits had to say about their hobbit
feet slippers oh people slipping
everywhere number nine no there isn't
only one universal Middle Earth accent
it wasn't a full Irish accent so it was
like a half of English markella
Kavanaugh along with the other actors
heavily relied on a dialect coach to
help them through the long shooting it
really must have been hard for Marcella
to shake off that Australian accent
number 10 you'd think a nobleman like
Kevin would do anything for the cause
without asking questions but for the
actor Leon wadham when asked to make his
life of the DP easier for a scene he
became very reluctant but at the same
time I would like to look cool doing
this all he had to do was switch up his
horse riding style to hold the light in
his dominant hand which actually turned
out to make more sense for the character
that actually helps with the story
because he's out of his element number
11. Sarah zuang obani and many other
cast members spend hours in the makeup
chair so the best way to pass the time
singing songs of course being a hobbit
means putting in the work for
Prosthetics and makeup but Sarah knows
how to turn a boring time into a
song-filled one she explained actually
we had a lot of fun in the makeup chair
two and a half hours sounds like a long
time but actually we had a great time so
it was like No Time passed
number 12 being far away from home for
anyone is hard especially if it's for
years at a time as the rings of power
were at one point the only show shooting
in the world during the pandemic this
meant that the cast could not see their
families for almost two years but this
experience as hard as it was proved to
be a major milestone for the cast's
relationship as a whole sazanim boniadi
said we filmed during a pandemic a
global pandemic it was difficult because
we were away from loved ones for almost
two years and our support systems but
what that did is it sort of forced us to
lean on each other and that is a bonding
experience like no other number 13 there
are a ton of nostalgic characters and
locations that true J.R.R Tolkien fans
can spot in the series one broader
aspect being that each set seems
seamless with one another as if all of
Middle Earth was created in real life
for this production this adaptation also
introduces characters old and new that
have never been portrayed great on
screen before it inadvertently points
Tolkien fans back to the books and even
attracts new ones markella Kavanaugh
believes in this concept saying I hope
that they respond to this and connect to
it for sure but I also do hope that
there are kids that haven't been
introduced yet and that you know maybe
they will be inspired to go back to the
books and ReDiscover them or discover
them for the first time number 14 when
you have the money to create practical
weather elements this can create a lot
more added safety precautions during
shoots if that was when there'd be like
huge fans if there was fire there'd be
people in the fire department by adding
real elements to a scene you not only
save time in post-production but also
obtain the most convincing performances
by actors dangerous yes but what's so
bad about giving the poor makeup
Department a break number 15 one would
never think a scene like this would be
the most difficult to shoot but when you
have elves mixed with dwarves it is
going to be tough matching them up
executive producer Lindsay Weber says
the hardest scene to shoot was the
elrond and dwarf Prince during the force
Rock competition because of the fact
that they had to cheat the camera a
little to make the dwarves seem much
smaller than their counterparts all the
calculated math made for a tough time as
Weber likes to put it it is probably the
single most complex and Technical thing
we shot which you wouldn't think because
it's a bunch of guys walking around the
room but most of them are meant to be
one size and one is meant to be another
and that is a very complicated math
problem we're not saying we do anything
to be in The Lord of the Rings show but
we definitely power through the crazy
sets and heavy beards to be an extra in
this one maybe our detective skills
surprised some of you viewers were there
any secrets that you spotted while
watching the series tell us your
findings in the comments section below
[Music]